well everyday China edges closer to
overtaking the United States as the
world's richest country but just because
they're getting stronger economically
doesn't mean the Chinese people are more
free they're not China is still imprison
aiding imprisoning rather its Muslim
population in the West ordinary Chinese
still lose access to travel or education
if the government says they have poor
Social Credit and now a hacker has
discovered a bizarre Chinese database
that evaluated millions of Chinese women
on whether they were quote breed ready
Gordon Chang is accomplished author of
the coming collapse of China can't come
too soon he joins us tonight
Gordon thanks very much for coming on
what is breed ready mean and why would
the Chinese government be assessing that
well breed ready means that they are
able to breed children and the reason
why is because China has declining
demography you know if you start to look
at some of the statistics they're really
frightening so for instance last year
their birth rate fell about 12% perhaps
so the lowest rate in the history of the
People's Republic going back to 1949 and
we're seeing that the workforce has
already topped out the population as a
whole will top out soon China's
officials are just in a panic so they're
identifying women who are breed ready
but then what do they do with that
information is there gonna be a coercive
breeding program in China they're very
possibly could be because some Chinese
officials are now talking about having a
two-child policy which is not a maximum
to children but they're talking about
requiring couples to have two children
now of course China's not there yet but
you can see where they're going largely
because they've been taken by surprise
by collapsing demography they shouldn't
have been people have been warning
Chinese officials about this for the
last 15 years but they've sort of slept
off the warnings but you know a couple
years ago they really started to see the
consequences of declining demography but
I mean I've been hearing from Democrats
in this country who are very concerned
about having any kids because of global
warming it sounds like the Chinese
aren't as concerned about global warming
as we are
no and largely because every social
problem every economic problem they have
almost all of them are made worse by
declining demography and the Chinese
leaders start to notice and that's
starting with their economy because you
know they grew during what was called
the demographic dividend years that was
expanding workforce now the workforce
since the 2011 has started to get
smaller and it's gotten smaller fast so
we have the same demographic problems
here obviously and so does Western
Europe declining below replacement rate
we just import new people from the
developing world has it occurred to the
Chinese to do that no you know the
Chinese don't want to do that because
they have a system and then basically
it's based on racial superiority where
they do view the rest of the world in
inferior terms and you know Tucker on
demography within maybe three years for
the first time in at least 300 years
maybe all of recorded history China is
not going to be the world's most popular
Society the world's most popular Society
will be India and the Chinese both
disdain the Indians because of this
racial superiority view but also they
fear India so people are concerned that
China's seeing a closing window of
opportunity and will lash out on that
Himalayan border so very quick you just
said something that almost nobody ever
says which is that China may be the most
racist country the world may be after
North Korea but certainly it's right up
there the country is based on racial
superiority and yet liberals in this
country suck up to China constantly why
does no one ever put that out well you
know I that to me is a mystery because
this notion of hands superiority is bred
into the Chinese political system and
you see it for instance you know they
put on a skit on the china central
television program 900 million people
saw it that depicted Asch Africans as
primates and and it's just incredible
Tucker it's so believable but Jerry
Brown is happy to call them wonderful so
it's Diane Feinstein unbelievable
Gordon check it's great to see you I
hope we'll see you again soon thanks
thanks Tucker